[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
really really excited
about our next guest by the way i can i
paulie let me ask you this before i
bring in ed marinero there's like a
standard
ivy league joke he's probably heard a
bunch of times should i do it anyway or
should i not do it yeah you guys you ivy
leaguers gotta have that connection okay
all right so i'm gonna do that then but
ed marinero i think a lot of people know
him as the actor hill street blues and
otherwise
he set 16 college records
he was the first running back in ncaa
history to run for over 4 000 career
yards by the way that's back when
freshmen weren't allowed to play that
was 4 000 yards in three years he got
second in the heisman at cornell you
know how good you have to be to get
second in the heisman from cornell that
is unbelievable ends up getting drafted
in the second round by the vikings plays
in a couple super bowls has a nice nfl
career then had a great acting career
and it's ross tucker man thank you so
much for coming on the show
okay
sounds like it can be fun
so
before i get into the draft stuff ed my
question is does it still bother i know
you said it the other night that you're
72
does it still bother you like when you
go to bed at night that you didn't have
the grades to get into princeton and you
had to go to cornell
oh boy
i didn't know i was gonna have to deal
with this crap though
no you know what i i actually got put on
a wait list at princeton um
so it was uh
you know from new jersey i just wanted
to get further away from home so
princeton was not um
you know you know they
the problem was princeton they they uh
they found out that my parents were
married so i i got rejected so
shout out by the way
i know i know shout out by the way to
the princeton steven missions that would
have really helped our football team in
those three years if they had made sure
ed was in there and i got a lot of
questions
about the draft the other night i i
guess the first one is
when do they tell you
when do they ask you to do that and what
kind of guidance do they give before you
actually get a chance to go out there
and announce a pick
all right uh you know like people have
been asking me this for the last you
know
48 hours
so that uh i i got invited by the
vikings to come and do their draft party
in minneapolis
on
thursday okay
and you know it was kind of cool i mean
i don't have a whole lot of contact
anymore with the league or the vikings i
go back to their legends weekend anyway
so i uh i say sure so you know they fly
my wife and i out there and um
we had a good time in minneapolis got to
see some old teammates and then i go to
vegas for the nfl draft
now
you got to be honest i don't follow this
stuff
i'm not like you know i'm not one of
these draft junkies i i don't think i've
ever watched the whole thing so
so i get there and they're very nice to
me and
um
so i go to the
they pick me up and i go over to the
wherever they had the thing you know i
was a little
i think was at a hotel the
was it de blasio i don't remember anyway
so they bring me in and
i go to the green room where all the
other presenters are you know i'm
hanging out with like marcus
marcus allen and uh
sebastian meniscoco who's a great
comedian who i think is great
larry zonka so it's cool so
it's it's a little chaotic backstage you
know in this green room so they come up
and say okay ed you're you're the second
person to go
i go okay you know so i'm getting ready
and i said
one i said what what do you
what do i do i mean do i go out there
and and um
let me just say this first so they
before this whole thing started they
brought the everybody all the presenters
out onto this stage okay
in front of the crowd i mean this crowd
was freaking enormous i've never seen
that
i felt like i was at woodstock you know
it went forever and i'm like
whoa
i said this is crazy
so then we go back in and they tell me
because you're on you're on you're the
second person to go so okay so i'm
getting ready and
and then
my son
text my wife and say
that's not going on next the vikings
just traded their pick
so
okay
so then they come out said you're not
going on next you're gonna i said so
when am i gonna go on it would probably
be like an hour i said okay so i'd go
backstage i
have a
brew or two you know i'm talking to
everybody you know and having a good old
time
and then again there's all this and
these people with headphones are walking
around they go excuse me
hey um when i go out there
i mean what do i do i mean do i just
read the thing and go okay yeah yeah i
go
okay just you know read i mean can
can i say anything do you want me to say
anything like yeah yeah i mean can i
have some fun they go oh yeah that's
good they like it when you have fun
okay
now
no one said to me
hey ed
you got 60 seconds
okay so let's get it over with you know
do what you do by the way no one said
anything to me and you know what i asked
multiple times
what do i do and no one can give me a
definitive
answer and i'm not watching what the
other people are doing i didn't even
they had tv's i could i couldn't hear
what the other presenters were doing
right
so i go out there again i see this crowd
and all of a sudden my adrenaline starts
going you know
i've been in the entertainment business
for 40 years okay
this is a guy like this is my dream come
true you know i mean i'm looking out
there and i see them they're cheering
and yelling and i just got you know so
i'm having fun i'm going to have some
fun
you know i i
yeah people said that you know i was
talking about myself who loved that who
am i going to talk about
so i you know i get out there and
i'm just reflecting a little bit about
my draft experience but i thought it was
funny and a lot of people really enjoyed
it
and
you know then i'm going along and blah
blah blah you know and i kind of knew
you know i was pushing the envelope a
little bit but again i had no
i was enjoying the crowd was responding
then this this woman comes out
and i thought she was gonna get like
will smith me you know
she comes out and she goes she did
something and i go no i didn't really
hear what she said but i got the hint
you know come on moving on so i i read
the thing
and um
there you go and i go off stage and
nobody said anything to me you know like
reflecting back i think they were
ignoring me
that that was gonna be my question what
was the reaction afterwards when you
walked up because you knew that she came
out and
kind of cracked the whip so when you
went in there and did they nobody say
anything to you they just kind of like
looked the other way
yeah you know i i kind of i was in my
own little world at that point um
and you know i i i just i i thought
i know i know the funny part was and i
don't know if you could
hear it
but when she came out
and did the whole thing
the crowd booed her
they booed her and you know again this
was happening all so fast
ed question do you think they were
booing her or do you think they were
booing you
no they weren't booing me they weren't
for me you know what
what's funny is
you know i
probably several of the people out there
were blue mountain state fans you know
you know guys in your 20s and 30s yeah
former tv show you ron yeah and they
were drunk and they wanted you know they
wanted something
i mean
go goats
no right they wanted to be entertained a
little bit nobody was doing that not
that i knew what people were doing but
you know i just wanted to have some fun
and you know i was
i was like
blown away by the reaction i mean from
people i mean but my twitter you know i
don't do a lot of social media stuff but
my twitter thing got just bomb and you
know
it's like 90 90 of people thought it was
great
and then i had
that 10 that like thought i was the
worst person in the world you know i
mean
how could i do that you're not the worst
person in the world i understand i
understand that but there are people out
there
again i have never been in any like a
twitter war
coming after me i'm gonna be like
insulting me one one guy
you know one guy said call me a d-list
actor you know
he
i'm i'm at least a seedless actor i'm
not a feminist actor talking with uh ed
marinero here on the dan patrick show
ross tucker filling in for dan as you
can tell ed got a lot of attention for
his announcement of the vikings second
round pick which by the way ed was back
in 1972 16 ncaa records got robbed of
the heisman trophy in my opinion
by pat sullivan back in 71. here's the
question i've always wanted to ask you i
think to my knowledge i think i met you
one time somewhere i can't remember but
here's my question
i know you get asked this all the time
nfl or actor like let's say you can only
pick one
you know like or maybe it's heisman or
an emmy like you're 20 years old knowing
what you know now you're 72
someone said ed you got to pick elaine
you get to do hill street blues and win
an emmy or you get to be an nfl player
and when you win the heisman and you win
the super bowl and you play 10 years
which one would you pick if you could
all because that like most people have
dreams those are like their two dreams
like to be an actor on tv or to be an
nfl player you did both which dream is
better i'm dying to know
you know that's a tough one only because
as a athlete you know you have you know
a certain
lifespan right
and as an athlete you know you can't you
know i don't want to blow my water and
have my life over at 30. right so i
would have to say like acting you know
obviously you have a you know actors
don't retire they either can't remember
their lines anymore or they die all
right so what what if you could only act
until you were 30 what if it's the exact
same amount of time you could have been
on hill street blues till you were 30 or
you could have been in the nfl till you
were 30. ross what am i going to do
after 30. that's a that's a terrible
question you have a degree from cornell
oh okay so i could do something else
yeah yeah
what i would have done in if i hadn't
done either one of those two okay
um i would say
uh
you know what i got more um
kind of
self-satisfaction out of my athletic
career than my acting career i mean i
think my athletic career
required a lot more um
you know commitment dedication right
anybody can be an actor if you have a
pulse you could put yourself in you know
and and you know it's remember acting is
and it was been a great life for me for
my family like i had a great career my
great people but you know it's just you
pretending to be somebody else
and and that's what
acting is all about as an athlete you
have to
you know
a lot of it's god-given but a lot of
it's developed it then you know it
requires you to be committed work hard
uh ups and downs overcome a lot of stuff
it's easy you know you
you you see it you see it happen all the
time and
a perfect example of what makes sports
great is tom brady i'm a tom brady fan i
mean here's a guy who had no
right to be the the greatest of all time
when you look at his early career six
round draft pick you know back up
quarterback for four years
he never
lost his his his uh
his personal self-esteem he he
you know stayed positive and look what
he did that's the great thing about
sports
acting you know is is kind of
you know it's
it's serendipitous you know you got to
get really lucky you can get really
lucky as an actor but sports you got to
have the goods yeah you got to earn it
ed really appreciate the time i thought
it was hilarious friday night um i don't
like that you're getting all kinds of
flack awesome guy awesome to talk to
unbelievable career both football and
acting thanks so much for coming on the
show
okay russ thanks a lot man hope we can
meet in person again that would be great
ed marinero
former nfl running back college football
hall of famer
of course an actor on hill street blues